what is the advice that you give to
somebody who has an artistic aspiration
don't have a plan B go all in there's no
no other alternative it it is a highrisk
high reward Endeavor and the competition
is so high there's so many talented
people that want it you know there is a
great life at the other end of it uh
with both artistic and monetary reward
so it's a really attractive best case
outcome but if you want to get there
just being talented is not going to be
enough like how do you how do I get
famous if you start in that end of Fame
then then you're then you're done you
have to fall in love with the craft and
you have to become obsessed with the
craft and continue to hone that and then
the success will come